we want to keep the unity and cohesion
within the union during a dynamic period
which is marked by challenges breaks it
in the same time the bridge in between
institutional cycles in the same time
one of the most important issues that I
think we tackle today which is the next
multi-annual financial framework and
last but not least of course the
European elections our aim is to advance
as much as possible on this nation with
direct impact on the daily life of the
European citizens we had this one in
exchange of views on accordion exposed
to this information this information has
become one of the greater challenges to
our democracies in order to be effective
we need joint efforts of the you Member
States and civil society we need action
we need the fast and urgent action we
were view to the elections for the
European Parliament that I only
mentioned is all about you to increasing
resilience is not about only this
information is about it's about
cybersecurity it's about all the aspects
that could be linked
with increasing resilience ease regions
of our societies not protect and defend
democratic processes that bothers the
odds faucets in them
mr. Holman Cherokee home that my
colleague is acted Yetta AG minor heart
Godsey meet him outside it's common to
the snakes to attend the chef de Gong
vanilla for osk mucin plasticky summed
virtue of the hilarity I encrypt women
that night soon will let's assume from
eatonville come up I'd splats flew still
mighty then can I'm food winter a
psychic for up cheated off of a patient
house eyelets Carmen I am enjoying this
instrument areum getting reps Assuan
firm stubby little chops and victim
Ferrara it splits it with oil pressure
with the ups fake kite sign